une autre personne l'a bien connu c'est
soeur emmanuelle elle l'avait rencontré
au caire quand elle s'occupait de ces
chiffonniers olivier théron et est allé
lui rendre visite dans le var elle
évoque le souvenir de mère teresa mais
vous allez le voir elle le fait au
présent j'ai beaucoup plus prompt je les
regarde et j'ai senti que dans cette
salle quelque chose d'autre c'est à dire
que et elle transpire
elle transpire pour m'expliquer la force
elle est fragile mais ce jour là elle
était aussi fait il était vraiment
failli échec comme l'expliqué à travers
ce port qui était déjà à ce sujet et
bien j'avais quelque chose tu m'as naît
et on avait envie en la regardant se dit
je vais travailler davantage cette femme
chez de l'epr diable doit aussi aller
jusqu'au bout on peut tueur aller plus
loin dans l'amour
donc le message - qu'elle m'a donné j'ai
bien lu deux qui n'ont ressenti de la
même manière c'est un peu moi va au-delà
fatick trahi par un peu plus ce combat
encore davantage de choses que je peux
dire que chaque fois que je pense à elle
c'était dans les moments où justement il
ya des mamans ozouf est-ce que je vais
pas pouvoir m'arrêter
non tu t'arrêtes papa non du battage un
nom qui doit sauver ses enfants à
travers le monde
chez chat je crois que l c'est un
détonateur de force et à détonateur
d'amour il ya des donateurs de joie elle
est toujours elle veut toujours de la
joie j'ai été très frappée de saint
amour force et joie et puis
naturellement les radiations de l'amour
du christ dans l'homme
ça ça vaut la peine est de nouveau